[Music]
your skincare routine is something to
behold you know the weekly face mask and
the rolly I don't even know what all of
our Tools in our bathro do I just know
that they're yours one of my first
girlfriends who told me I would be
handsome if I didn't have such bad skin
and it just locked into my
[Music]
soul woo what's up this is John with the
Dr John deloney
show show about your mental and
emotional health and your marriage and
your kids all of
it real people going through real
stuff all over the world and we all meet
here and we sit together and we sit with
one another and we try to figure out
what to do next if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at 1844 693
3291 or go to John dooney.com
ask ask and this is a huge
show we did it guys this is our
500th
episode
500 after the first one I thought there
would be five I mean seriously I'm
curious did you when we were down in the
dungeon and we did that first one that
was pretty rough it was incredible on
all parts I mean for all of us I think
we had to reshoot that one didn't we
yeah we did it was great I wasn't going
to say that but we did yeah we had to
redo it um did did you ever think we'd
make it to 500 that's pretty incredible
I didn't even I couldn't even WRA my
head around that no cuz every time I
left I was in a bad mood I thought James
was going to kill us I didn't you didn't
even know what day it was I just felt
like every no I did not and I didn't
realize how fast it would come either
like it just happened overnight and I
didn't know I mean when you like like
hey I'm starting a show with my name on
it you hope people listen to it I had no
idea it would be as big as it as gten so
the whole thing is just like a glitch in
The Matrix it's pretty amazing but our
500th episode and we racked our brain
for what could we do that was special
for the 500th
episode and we talked about getting some
famous people in here and we talked
about doing some silly
things and then I had one request I
asked one
person and finally she said
yes and I as just a general rule of life
I don't get nervous I've been in some
wild situations and I don't get nervous
about anything and I am very nervous
about this
because today's guest for our 500th
episode is the original Dr deloney my
wife Sheila
deloney we talk about um and this is I
mean we're kind of out there but we talk
about
um living with somebody with 8
ADHD not me just kidding what's it like
living and loving somebody who can be
hard to live with and love and um
somebody who's late to everything and
somebody who leaves piles of themsel all
over the place and somebody who leaves
piles all over the place and somebody
who I don't know isn't perfect excuse me
Mr Perfect anyway we also talk about
identity
and her journey from
being a really respected Elementary
School teacher to a inter like a
nationally known researcher Dr
deloney to a husband who was really
struggling with some mental health
challenges to hey Miss to stay-at-home
mom to now she's a um celebrated author
and a coach she coaches
women but that's been a really hard
transition because the world has told
her she's failing every step of the way
and she talks really openly about that
Journey what the impact with our kids
the impact on our marriage and then she
goes on to tell some things that I wish
she had kept quiet and she tells things
about
me that probably shouldn't have been
told in public and here we are there was
one moment when she said something and I
caught out of the corner of my eye Kelly
just like put both hands in the air just
to cheer and I was like oh I wish he
hadn't have said that and so it's all
here on the internets forever so please
buckle up and sit tight and listen into
my conversation with my extraordinary
brilliant and beautiful
wife the um heartbeat behind all of the
stuff that I do the original great Dr
Sheila deloney check it
out here we are here we we are thank you
for being on the show you're welcome
thanks for having a
show let's start that way how many times
have you listened to the show I think
three you you have really yeah I think
I've told you each time I thought you
just did it once and that's when I was
on somebody else's show cuz you want to
see if we could still be married no I've
listened to three of yours really yeah
the amaas because I want to know what
you're saying oh about you yeah if
you're talking about other
people I don't listen
yeah you might be talking about me then
I think I talk about you a lot probably
and that's the other reason I don't
listen what I don't know I don't have to
be mad about so one of the questions we
get almost um on a daily or weekly basis
is something that at the beginning I
thought you might be sending in over and
over and over again because it's our
house and so but I don't think it is I
think it's something that is just
pervasive so
how have you managed how do you manage
to live with and be married and most of
the time love all the time love most of
the time like um somebody with ADHD
somebody who struggles with anxiety or
OCD some of these some of these big
dragon labels how have you learned to
create a life with it with that within
that by the way we have not prepped this
I am not an expert on any of those
things you're an expert on love listed I
am an expert on you so you're the only
person that I've been married
to so said how have you how have you
stayed in love with me I'm going to I'm
going to keep it to what's it like to
live with you and love
you with the Tendencies You may have
that may may be generalizable but I
don't know I think the biggest one is a
change in
expectations so I may think think that
tidiness is a priority among all adults
and that turns out not to be true so
where I would prefer people are coming
over let's tidy up the
house I prefer like people are coming
over let's be on let's be on the front
porch or be mowing the front yard yes
because if they're coming at 6 I can
start mowing at 5:30 and duh plenty of
time so so shifting expectations I'm not
GNA have a tidy house and that is just
the life that I chose but I never have a
boring house either so so I I in my head
remember it approximately 10 years ago
is that there was like a distinct change
and then probably 5 years ago when we
were leaving Texas and moving here and
things were just a mess that there was
like yet another
change and I felt the air leave the
house in a good way way like there was
the pressure that I lived to that was me
giving up is that is that is yeah was
that like I quit um but there was like a
distinct shift and in an odd way and you
can tell me if I'm wrong I felt like
without that constant I'm not doing this
right I then I have felt space to then
start to slowly quietly inch my way
towards like being a little more tidy
sometimes yeah yeah that's true and some
of it is letting go of expectations
other people like when you name those
markers 5 years ago 10 years ago that's
also when as an adult I've quit being so
consumed with what other people think of
me or think of us and so some of the the
buildup was what are other people going
to think if John's still in the shower
when they get to our house or what are
our parents going to think if they show
up in the house is a wreck or the front
yard has weird things piled and stacked
here and there um and just coming to a
place where I don't know this is how we
live we live in chaos
and welcome welcome to yeah rather than
putting out some sort of trying to
pretend that we live a tidy life when we
don't that sounds
like an uncomfortable
response that I think is pretty powerful
so tell me if I'm wrong here what I'm
hearing you say is
when
you I'm going say do the work but that
doesn't necessarily mean that but when
you started doing the work on you
MH and we stopped butting heads on it's
got to look like this like but I've got
so much going on here right and then it
was almost like
when yeah when you
went and you can call it giving up I
would say making peace with the other
side of it is
um I don't know I just felt there was
such more space in the house for joy and
peace and laughter which then for me
calms everything down and then it's like
oh I see that pile I'm not going to get
to it but I see it now I've never seen
that pile before CU I was too busy
trying to like walk on a on a rope that
I didn't understand
yeah and I think also when you think of
those markers 5 years ago 10 years ago 5
years ago when we moved here I stopped
working in schools 10 years ago I
stopped working
full-time if we were both still leaving
the house one of us on time and getting
home in the evening and then coming in
and like dinner's got to be ready and
then we got to start the next day and we
need the decks cleared to start a whole
new day if we were both doing that I
don't know that I could have come to
that place
of whatever you called it coming to
peace with it what is it I've the story
I've told myself over time is especially
in the last couple years as it's become
incredibly important for me something
I'm trying to work on hard is being on
time
and it was when I it was when I started
working here and I wasn't the leader of
an organization and when you're a leader
of an organization you kind of live in a
bubble because everybody just mors to
what your
weirdness here there was like some
really poignant like you're being very
disrespectful of all of the people in
this room or and you actually you see
here there's a whole team of people and
if I roll in six minutes late it's like
and I'm thinking I'll get the show done
Show's going to be fun I've already
checked the calls I know what coming
I'll be all right but there's still five
or 10 or 15 people sitting there waiting
and how have you navigated just that
honest feeling like like sitting in the
car waiting for us to go to church or
like we're going to leave at 5:30 for
our date cuz we're nerds and it's 6:15
and I'm getting out of the shower
like I talk through that
like feeling of
disrespect oh that's another one there
there's two parts to it and and really
though it overlaps with what I was
saying before some of it is expectation
I just don't expect to be on time for
things um I think our church Community
does not expect us to be on
time our kids don't expect you to be on
time I know and we try to make
adjustments like telling you it's really
7:15 is when we need to leave when three
of the four of us know it's really 7:30
but this gives us a better shot at
leaving on time um so some of it's
giving up like just like oh we're just
not going to be and then some of it is
letting go of if somebody wants to give
us a dirty look when we walk in late to
church well okay and just not being as
concerned about that um and then the
other thing again because I'm not
working full-time I work from home I
work for myself so you're not causing me
to be late for something so it's less
the stakes are lower so I can give you
more room to be late and it
doesn't I don't know so when I talk to
people out on the road they say it must
be so fun like just this picture of like
y'all's house sounds so
fun I know there's another side of fun
which is exhausting exhausting so um how
do you navigate that because I know that
I someone who like is working hard but
man time is hard for me uh I I'm really
I've called a few experts like cuz I'm
at the end of my rope on like clutter
like and we're not hoarders but I got
soone just stuff I just got Stu we not
but I just got clutter and um but I'm
I'm at this weird place like I'm I'm out
of Tricks right the tricks that I use to
like cut weight the tricks I use to
exercise the tricks I use for nutrition
don't work for that for some reason so
there's the other side of that like oh
my gosh it must be so fun and those are
hilarious and our daughter's a a
hurricane she's hilarious and our son is
so witty and funny and they're always
cracking jokes and there's the other
side of that which is just exhausting
how do you navigate that I take naps
when I go to bed
early
um what else do I have I check out yeah
yeah again it's that same bucket of just
letting go you didn't trick me you
weren't on time while we were dating and
had all your stuff together then so I
knew what I was getting um you know I
used to say it's a good thing you're
cute yeah that's the same thing I said
about our kids
um but as I'm getting older I can't lean
on that anymore you better see figure
something out I know um what about this
uh folks who struggle mightily with
anxiety and ADHD um and even into
depression often have really
negative self-image cuz it's like I know
you know what I mean I know that I'm not
on time I know that and I worked really
hard to get my breakfast done I worked
really hard to be present with the kids
in my head I'm like you're going to
spend some time with your wife you're
going to make sure eat a healthy
breakfast you're going to do all these
things and then it's like the freaking
clock won't stop spinning and so and
that's just one thing like there's
moments of of Lucidity where I see like
this house is a disaster and 97.8% of it
is me and the rest of it is a middle
school boy right it's embarrassing like
it's it's shameful how do you navigate
loving somebody who like doesn't always
share that same love for themselves
I don't know I don't know that
I'm doing it
well um I I guess part of it
is loving you and
so beyond that I don't know what to
do but I can love you without loving
your behaviors and be in relationship
with you I think maybe this is another
switch that has happened
is to stop trying to be in relationship
with your behaviors and your mess and
what that is and just kind of jump over
that and be in relationship with you the
person who means well and is always kind
and has a million other things that I
love and if you know if I stacked those
up because I love lists if I stack those
up on list that way outweighs the fact
that you leave your stuff everywhere um
everywhere I get it's worth the trade I
guess if this if this is the trade to
make like well you get this great guy
but he's a mess well yeah I'm GNA I'll
deal with the
mess I would say the greatest gift you
bring me is like a
constant stop pulling on your shirt you
don't look unattractive and stop you can
leave that stuff there I'd rather you
come to bed or like there's some moments
that I have felt especially last four or
five years where it's been very much a
focus
on um like you just mentioned like
you're good with me and for some weird
reason that has slowly begun to let the
shame smoke out and almost like a
release valve then I can't describe it
other than people with ADHD and OCD and
anxiety are so frustrating to be in
relationship with because it's so like
why do you have to be like that and it's
like I don't know right it's like we
were talking with our kids the other day
like one of our children it was like
this does that feel good and they were
like no it doesn't feel even good and
but in a strange
way you leaning into
that instead of like setting a marker
over here and like you will meet this
expectation and for me and my body
response to that is like that's my dad
whose expectation I'm still trying to
meet that's my teacher who that one time
or the football coach who I'm still
instead of that it's like moving all the
way up here and be like I will love you
despite the piles I'll end for some
reason I start to see them and be like
all right I'm get that I'm gonna get
that taken care of I do know in our in
our like our kitchen area I Dro that
guitar and all that stuff right there in
that huge pile I know that I know it's
there but I saw it and even I was
leaving this morning I had to make a
choice between the pile and timeliness
and I chose being on time but I did see
it which is huge did you choose being on
time because you knew I was going to get
here first no um I chose being on time
because I had an announcement to make in
front of a thousand people so I had to
be there on that stage when the time
came but but it's it's there's been
times I've sent a text message like move
me to third because I'm coming in hot
four minutes later or whatever um but
some of that's just
being I know it's self-reinforcing over
the last six no probably over the last
year as I've tried to really work hard
especially at work on getting on time
there's like a like the there's more
peace like I feel better right being
here early and I can prepare and people
aren't stressed and people aren't
frustrated and trying to bite their
tongue around me or like Kelly who's not
biting her tongue and just letting it
fly right there's just a piece right um
and I'm slowly leaning into that which I
like but yeah so what I hear you saying
is me not shaming you helps you feel
less shamed but I don't even Tada but I
don't think I don't there's been some of
that both and we've both lobb back
grenad at each other over the course of
21 years but I think it's less that I
think it's more there was just a um like
there's a pair of glasses you wore that
was this is the way this is supposed to
be
and I kept saying but it didn't have to
be we could just stay up till midnight
and go to this punk rock show that
doesn't start till 1:00 a.m. and you're
like I know but for the next six days it
will take us that long to get back and
I'm like I know but it'd be so fun right
now all of this is problems for future
John and Sheila but right now and so
there's just that talk we and we've
laughed about it over 20 years like
thank God that I have you because
I I literally don't know where I would
be and the other side of it is like you
never would have been to a punk rock
show that is true I do want to point out
two things I'll answer but first because
I'm here part of the issue with your
timeliness is that you just mentioned
we're going to be out till midnight for
a punk rock show that starts at 1:00
a.m. and there's where the problem
starts in response those are the same
time basically uhhuh anything after 11:
and before 2: a.m. that's about the same
time it responds though some of it has
also been I quit picking up after you so
there was the it has to be this way so
I'm just going to do it all myself I
since you don't care about having a tidy
house and I do I'm just going to clean
up all your mess for you God I felt that
so then there was that res yeah super
rage
cleaning now I can be bopping in from
work like hey and it would just be wow
because you hadn't noticed the piles to
begin with so you also didn't notice the
absence of piles it was just like hey
guys what you've been doing all day yeah
and so that that was definitely a source
of builtup resentment um same with like
John you probably you're supposed to be
at work in 30 minutes and you're still
in my gym show haven't haven't showered
or anything so letting go of that and
like you want to have piles or even if
you don't don't want them you made piles
okay we're just going to live in a pile
house and I'm going to carve out a
little corner that I'm going to keep
tidy and no one else is allowed in my
corner hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow is isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free so maybe the second question most
common question I get is about role
identity especially for women MH and so
when I met you you were way smarter than
me yep not indicative of that one class
that we had where I got an A and you got
a
B after the professor tried to fight me
but it's cool and so then the next
um that that was incredible that was one
of my favorite moments of my life I know
um 25 years ago Hey listen I can't let
go that in high school football games I
can't let them go then you went and got
a master's
degree and you're the only person at the
time that I knew probably to this day
still that got a master's degree because
you want to be a better teacher you were
a school teacher like I want to do this
better and so we lived right down the
street from this major research
University and so and then you when got
a PhD and it was never in your mind like
I want to go be a research professor and
do all stuff it was like I want to
continue to be much better at this and I
never heard you say like I want to be a
principal or anything like I just want
to I want to learn so much so I can love
these kids and then I got a job in
another city
and you applied to all these it was a
small Texas town so you applied to all
these places and all these school
districts and they wouldn't hire you
because not even an interview yeah
because it was it was she ain't from
around here and it was just like wait
what look at the credential like n she's
not she's not one of us but you the two
job offers you got were two major
universities in that City and so you
launched into this career where you
became like an absolute gangster at
research professor and I would still be
piddling around with my Master's Degree
if you hadn't been had to blaze that
trail ahead of me cuz I didn't even know
what some of the words meant and I
didn't know where they posted the
assignment boards I didn't know any of
that stuff almost overnight you become
Dr deloney
and like the most revered and feared
education professor in that building
like your colleagues would tell you that
same thing you start writing like
research articles you're like presenting
across the country like all of a sudden
this thing that people work their whole
career for you wal stried in and were
pretty incredible and you had an awesome
team that supported you say I waled
right in but go ahead I'm saying like it
wasn't the intention right like it
wasn't like from day one that wasn't the
dream I'm going to go do this it was
like all right here's this incredible
opportunity and within four or five
years I mean you were it was
unbelievable right um the univers like
senior leadership was pulling you into
meetings and putting you on committees
and and your colleagues respected you
nationally
respected and then you're married to a
guy that went crazy and yeah a little
bit and so like I this is one of my big
like shame pillars that still haunts me
a little bit so you have this incredible
life right we got Hank he's a little
bitty kid and the whole Community loves
him the university community all the
students all of our students love him um
he's like all your colleagues especially
but all of our colleagues love him and
he's just kind of waltzes around on a
college campus just surrounded by love
and his um school was like we I walked
him to school and would walk to campus
and so we just had this perfect little
life except that your husband went mad
right Stone mad which means the life
wasn't perfect it wasn't perfect right
right right um
and so we left we took a $70,000
household income pay cut and we moved to
another city three hours away where I
was got a new job at a university that
still on on its face was a fancy pants
job but it was worth a much smaller
group of students and it was going to
give me some space to like get well
figure out what in the world's going
on and in that transition you made the
choice to not
pursue like working at a university
anymore but like okay I'm going to stay
at home and I'm going to have kids and
we're going to have multiple kids and
I'm going to work part-time at a local
school and I remember watching with awe
as you navigated the toggle of Dr
deloney Dr deloney Dr deloney to hey
Miss like right there right Dr deloney
from graduate students and you know
President of University to hey Miss by
kindergartner who was super
disrespectful and like a classroom
teacher who was like oh my gosh she's
just an aid right
and I watch like uh uh like you know as
I'm in my own chaos trying to get well
and I'm watching you pingpong this thing
back and forth and then we you know and
I've talked a little bit about like you
know we had several miscarriages in a
row and navigating grief on top of hey
Miss on top of what are we going to be
and it just felt like you wore a lot
when it came to Identity and then we
pack up and move and I get we get our
Dream opportunity and Nashville and at a
university and then now as Hank says I'm
a YouTuber and I do a whole other job
but it's afforded us a different kind of
life and so in this last season you you
know become a bestselling author and
you've you went and got your master
gardener license and you're Drive 17
hours a day getting kids all over
creation because we live out in the
woods
um how do you navigate how have you
navigate if I look back over the last 10
years that's a lot it's a lot not just
professionally it's a lot of identity
shifting
M how do you navigate that that was a
lot it was of
question uh I'll take it in stages I
guess so the shift from University to
public school part-time hourly worker
that was that was a lot of ego
shift um like you said I I had status I
had autonomy and then I went to like
sign your time sheet and not invited to
any meetings of any
significance even though I may have been
the most qualified person in the
building maybe not but it yes you are it
felt like it at times um and so that was
hard at the same time it's what I wanted
that the thing that didn't happen is I
kind of took this leap from Identity as
a professor to Identity as more more
leaning into the stay-at-home mom thing
but then our oldest started school and
there was no other baby yeah to hold and
so there was a gap between the identity
that I left and the identity I wanted to
embody and there was a gap and so that
was the hardest season because I had let
go of one and hadn't grabbed on Vine
there's no Vine coming yeah there's
nothing coming not that having only one
child makes you less of a mom or less
whatever but he started school and so
those yeah like the actual hours of the
day and it was hard too in terms of ego
I would go to dinners with you where
before we kind of walked into a room
like a work event we kind of walked in
as as a power couple which you know when
I was 30 that there was mutual respect
it was the doctor's delone right yes and
we both had she's the stable one he's
the neurotic one but they're both yeah
we both had research agendas and our vas
looked good and whatever um and so then
to go if I went with you to a work event
it was oh there's John's wife and that
was like what um oh yeah or you know
inevitably the person sitting next to
you at the chicken and rice dinner would
say what do you do and it it's like I
used to be a yeah yeah it stung like I
used to be but I'm not quite it was just
a yeah so that was a tough one the
transition when we moved here I had
already
reestablished a healthier I think or or
maybe not healthier but just a second
half of life kind of identity that
wasn't so wrapped up in what am I going
to tell people out a dinner or how do
people see me when we walk into a room
but just I have figured out who I am who
I want to be
and that identity transfers you know
wherever you want to go whatever however
you're making your
money
um I felt I felt more solid in
mechanistically my identity how did you
unhook that cuz that most most people go
to the grave in that Gap um I I talk
often
about 60-year old guys still telling
High School football stories cuz that's
the last time they had an identity biger
themselves right or the folks who are
veterans that I've worked with it's like
25 years ago was your last deployment
and that's still the story of who you
are right um how did you make that
switch because that that buries most
people yeah um part of it's therapy for
sure and then part of it um in that Gap
um my grandma was her health was
declining she was in the last years of
her life dementia was um you know kind
of taking
over and so I felt as I was grieving my
own pregnancy losses I was also grieving
the loss of my grandma
who um is just such a an important
figure in my life and so realizing like
oh any kids I have at this point aren't
going to know her and she's not going to
know them and there was the grief in the
loss of that um so in that time you know
actually right around the time when
Josephine was born I started writing my
grandma's stories because I wanted our
kids I wanted my cousin's kids I I
wanted people to know her stories and
her mom's stories and the these weren't
these weren't tidy lives they lived they
were they were pioneers and they lived
hard lives but they did it with so much
joy and optimism and and love and and
care and so I started writing down those
stories and I realized oh this is giving
me so much life back because um when you
have small children and a husband who
may have
ADHD everything you do in a day gets
undone like you change diapers you cook
meals you do
laundry pick up the house and the next
day there's a dirty diaper and a pile of
laundry and dirty dishes in the sink and
someone needs a
snack and so it just felt
like you know I I know the stuff about
like pouring into your kids and all that
but on a day-to-day
basis nothing sticks the worst it's all
it all has to be done again the next day
but I found that when I got up to write
if I wrote 500 Words that morning those
500 words were still there the next day
and I could build on them and so
building a Writing Practice was really
um getting my life back and
claiming claiming a piece of the day for
myself um you know it reactivated that
that intellectual side and I think for
the first time really turned on a
creative side that I hadn't you know in
in academic writing it's mostly straight
forward
and um it's not as creative in the same
kind of way and so um I found my
creative voice and I realized I can
connect these Generations that won't
know each other and won't meet each
other but I can connect them and then in
a larger sense uh connect my grandma's
Life and Legacy to to a broader audience
too so here's a big secret that nobody
knows actually probably everybody knows
but especially the first like nine
months I was doing this show I've got
all this expertise sitting with people I
don't say expertise like from a clinical
I mean from a clinical and academic
standpoint but like years of practice
just sitting with folks and I would get
such and such a call like um they would
you know Kelly or Jenna would send the
calls this Kelly back in she'd send the
calls hey this calls what's coming
tomorrow and I would ask you like hey
this person's said this this and this
and this I'm thinking about saying
whatever and you would say oh good God
do not say that God help you don't say
that why don't you ask him this and this
and I was like like oh that's
genius and
so like this is just us being as honest
as we can you're a way better writer
Than Me by a long shot my mom called
this weekend she's editing your new book
she called this weekend was like hey
this is amazing I quit editing it and I
just started reading it and I just sat
there and read the whole thing
through like just in an honest honest
way you could probably do this job
better than me no not that all the
peripheral stuff yeah but when it comes
to like hey what should I say why don't
you ask him this I'm like oh that's
genius right or when it comes to writing
here's your husband getting prayed
around on the bestseller lists and like
she look how many books we sold this
month and how do you handle that because
I know it sucks like there's a there's a
good part because we share the same
checking account and yes we do you know
my my boss flies us around the country
sometimes and that's awesome
but there's like a reality to that yeah
and that's when I'm
still uh still in the
Reckoning yeah but again it goes back to
I have a core
identity um so so yes it's hard to be an
indie author and I have to hire someone
to edit and do cover design and I do all
of my own marketing which is the only
reason I agreed to be on your
podcast
um and so there's that and then you have
people who just like just a machine that
just does all of this and it's amazing
to watch and what I find when I find
myself saying must be nice that's not me
being mad at you that's me being jealous
and the flip side of that is I would
never trade with you because I have
absolute autonomy I make all the final
choices in my business and you have to
have your face on your cover of every
book right I have to fight for
everything
artist to do the cover of my book so a
different kind of artist guess um so I
would never trade
that ever um I set my own schedule and I
see few clients in the summer so that I
can have flexibility with our kids like
I I get to make all the choices and I
think for me autonomy is is maybe the
the highest value in what I'm looking
for in and autonomy is a to yeah for
sure privilege I mean your path has led
me to this place where I can have that
privilege and you know being an indie
author is not going to pay all our bills
so I couldn't do it at all if it weren't
for year half of the the
partnership but it sounds like you're
holding both and that's I it's I to me I
think both ands solve so much of what's
going on in our discourse in the country
and in our homes and marriages with our
kids it's like I feel this way and I'm
going go into the next yeah right thing
yeah it also you know sometimes it
does
um yeah I I struggle with the fact that
our daughter never met me when you were
a gangster yeah yeah but you're a
gangster now it's just a different kind
of gangster
yeah yeah um she did ask one day in the
car if you had a business what would you
call it I said well actually I do have a
business and I got to name it if you
were a doctor what kind would you be
well I am one so yeah um and so
sometimes it surprises me like oh yeah
you never knew you never knew that part
um you've probably shared this story but
she does think well she doesn't anymore
but there was a moment when she thought
I was famous and you weren't pretty
awesome because she saw me signing books
for a friend and her eyes got wide and
she said are you famous and our friend
of course answered yes did you not know
your mom's famous and that was news to
her news to me too but she had never
heard anyone say that you're famous and
she's never seen you sign books so um
yeah when I brought my book in I was
like I wrote one and she goes dad that's
not a real book like your face is on it
I like no it counts and she's like it
doesn't count dad and she's holding on
to that she will not let you yes have
that no and she gets up from her mom yes
it's her best
quality this episode is sponsored by
better help hey what up what up it's
delone this time of year can be so hard
and Seasonal effective disorder is real
when I moved here the time change caught
me off guard it was dark at 4:30 and I
was ready for bed at like 6:45 at night
things weren't as fun even food tasted
different and now I know how to prepare
my body I go outside and enjoy nature I
stick to an exercise routine I got a
light box and I intentionally connect
with people another thing that has
helped me therapy therapy can be a
bright spot even when the Sun goes down
too soon something positive to help you
feel grounded and give you the tools to
man manage the way your body is changing
during the seasons if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit into your
schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
licens therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for No Charge find
your bright spot this season with a
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com dealone
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
dealone all right so we're back and I I
know we're running out of time Kelly so
all hustle on this one um oh this is the
one I wanted the most time for okay good
we spent all day all right go ahead all
right so this is the 500th episode which
still blows my mind I think it's like
the drum roll moment to give everybody
the dirt what's it like to live and be
in the ecosystem
system of kind of a
Maniac husband who's a YouTuber and
who's what's it like to live with John
thought that was the first question no
that's like living with somebody with
ADHD you just did a very good coaching
move and you said like I don't know ADHD
but I know my husband like that okay
yeah so behind closed doors we've
established I'm messy yeah and can I say
there's a difference between messy and
gross yeah I'm not gross no but I am
messy
yes yes so I will just defend you on the
not gross thing okay good um I'm overly
hygienic I think yes you are I I could
share that um your skincare routine is
something to behold and it always has
been that predates even our dating I
think I dated one of my first
girlfriends who told me I would be
handsome if I didn't have such bad skin
and it just locked into my soul yeah it
did all those voices um so you know the
weekly face mask and the rolly I don't
even know what all of our Tools in our
bathroom do I just know that they're
yours and it didn't occur to me till I
was in my 40s that I should wash my face
every night so I'm 63 and look how good
I look just kidding yeah um so that's
there's that um can I talk about
grilling you can talk about it it's
embarrassing John is a novice griller
I'm embarrassing when it comes to it and
I don't know why like you get so
embarrassed about this this is one of
those things it doesn't bother you until
people come over and I'm the one at the
grill with the burgers or the steak or
whatever and then I see it wash over you
and I just think why I cuz I've had
multiple you're the best state cooker
I've ever met ever it's incredible and
there's been
multiple usually Texas males but there's
occasional Texas males Tennessee males
who are like hey why your wife grilling
it's like well cuz she's awesome I don't
know how and it's this look of like hey
why are you with that woman and it's
like cuz I'm cheating on my wife it's it
be very similar just that look of
disdain
and how dare you man like you let us all
down I mean you can't be good at
everything and you know so many things
don't know how to cook in general I'm
not good you been trying we eat was it
hanking dead mush yeah just opening a
few cans and adding them to ground beef
eggs yeah into a bowl yeah I Han we call
it Hank and dead mush it was fantastic
the name of
it all right so I can't cook and I've
got an elaborate skincare routine what
else I'm late allegedly You Dropped a
baton in high school bring that was the
first story I ever heard from your
friends about you and they have probably
still not let it go cuz I didn't drop it
it was that's how far back I have to go
to have dirt like I feel like you
probably knowing
how I'm pretty open about stuff all your
voices that tell you how you're horrible
I have a feeling everyone's heard
everything you said something while we
were walking going on a weekly walks
last
week that when we were talking about
this I was asking if you're nervous or
not and you said I just want people to
know you're not as good as they think
that that you are yeah you're not as
good and you're not as bad yeah like I
think and that may be just the curse of
any public
person like Instagram can make things
look a certain way and you're probably
not that smart or that in tuned or that
whatever I don't know I don't follow you
on Instagram
um but probably you're not that good at
whatever it is but also you're not that
bad so whatever the critics are saying
or the comments are lobbing I I don't
know again but or however bad you say
that you are about things you're not
that bad either like I don't miss
appointments I'm 5 minutes late to
everything yeah you're a good guy who's
trying really hard sometimes you miss
but you're always trying but as Yoda
says that's not enough you're a regular
person I don't do Star Wars that's true
last thing what's your favorite thing
about people coming up to us while we're
having dinner together um when they walk
away I thought it was going be when they
told me how wonderful I am put their
hand up to your face like hold on I know
you in the middle of something romantic
but no I again I'm getting more used to
it and having to do my own like why does
that bother me so much mostly I like to
go through life
unnoticed so here I am look how much
work I've done um this is a lot of this
is years of therapy this is way to go
Holly way to go Hol um yeah so yeah I
still don't love it yeah and I
appreciate so much that they want to
acknowledge you and that they want to
like show gratitude or even share like
some impact you've had I love that I
just wish I didn't have to be part of it
which is why people may notice like I
thought your wife was here I have to go
to the bathroom she's in the parking lot
that's right yeah so I I don't love it
and I do appreciate it a while ago when
we were sitting down across this is
years ago sitting down saying like if
we're going to stay married we have to
like rebuild this thing from the floor
up and I remember as a part of that
series of conversations we had one of
the things I said that like it was so
embarrassing for me at the time I was
just so humiliated embarrassed but it
was like can you just tell me you're
proud of me and as I've I've gotten my
own therapy shout out Holly way'd to go
same therapist incredible as I've
gotten Weller if you
will I've begun to see that
everywhere like I begun to see that
what's that you do love me and that you
know as Berne Brown says whatever you go
looking for that's what you're going to
find and I was looking for all the ways
I was coming up short and I
missed
how all those ways you was you were
wrestling with your own stuff and at the
same time saying no no no I'm really I'm
really proud of
you one day um when I was working at
Belmont I come racing home for lunch and
i' forgotten
something and I grabbed something to eat
but I had forgotten something and then I
kissed you and as I was leaving the door
I mean leaving the house you said you
must be amazing at your job and I
stopped and dropped my shoulders and I
was
like she sees it but there's more she
sees
it and you said you followed up with cuz
you're such a disaster in every facet of
your life you must be so good when you
just get there and plug in and I
remember
thinking hey that's very true like I
think that all the other places I've
worked they put up with kind of the
maniacal whatever because when it went
down I was really good when it went down
and it was like got to fix the budget
someone's going to take their life like
delone will show up and he'll kill He
he'll just do a great job but we got to
deal with all this drumming going on
over here but it really was a turning
point like What
if I tried to be less of a disaster in
every part of my life and showed up
would it make showing up better and I
think over the last three to five years
I've proven that to myself that um kind
of like the artist it's like I got to do
drugs so I can write good songs then
they get sober and they realize their
songs are great U they're actually
better and clearer and their shows are
better um I don't know that was an
important moment for
me both you recognizing like you must be
good at your job
and man you're hard to be around but
that's also how I experience you in a
marriage like it's like what I was
saying I'll put up with the piles
because all the other stuff is so great
and in the stuff that really
matters you show up and you do a good
job you're a good dad and all that good
stuff all that good stuff but you're a
mess that's the trade I'm willing to
make a mess holistically yes you're
consistent I'm consistent hey I love you
thank you for being my friend love you
thanks for uh for being married to me
and for
coming out of the woods being on the
internets now forever forever yes yeah
don't make me regret it already and
you're beautiful thanks we won't regret
it thanks your skin looks
[Music]
good thank you love you're
welcome hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
dooney.com
oh we're back and so that's all out
there now that is all out there and as
you can see I'm married way above my
head I out kicked my coverage by a long
long way
and yeah did pretty good did pretty good
so hopefully you enjoyed that
conversation with uh me and my wife um
Dr lony and as we wrap up today's show
picked a song that she loved from loves
from one of her favorites of all time
from the great original Texas country
star George Straight song's called the
chair and it goes like this look excuse
me but I think you've got my chair no
that one's not taken I don't mind if you
sit here I'll be glad to share yeah it's
usually packed here on Friday nights oh
if you don't mind could I talk you out
of a light well thank you can I buy you
a drink oh listen to me what I mean is
can I buy you a drink anything you
please oh you're welcome well I don't
think I caught your name are you waiting
for someone to meet you here well that
makes two of us glad you
came
to tell you the truth that wasn't my
chair after
all I wish I wrote that song cuz my wife
would love me a little bit more and she
wouldn't tell all my secrets I love you
guys see you
soon